okay let's go for a new blitz game after
some hiatus I am wasn't completely away
it was just yeah getting involved in
playing on computer game and I just
couldn't stop playing so didn't really
get to make new videos okay um let's see
what we got here I'm playing the
national master from Canada and we've
got a modern defense played the solid
sis rely and we played somewhat unusual
was Queen e8 and not f.2d 7 now it's
going 45 write a three I thought was a
flexible move to have both an ID be five
and 94 vailable not sure what to play
now though the rookie won nothing to
discourage him from playing f5 okay a
sixsome three wins this night jump to be
five not sure how to best place the
pieces here you might go for knight c6
to get some pressure going on deform and
I'm not quite sure where the pieces
should be M should be placed here this
looks like a decent square yeah this is
interesting now teams may be really
threatening to take deform but not sure
the severe threat maybe just night see
to be sure to see to
could also bring up ideas of putting the
bishop to be 3 later your king air but
you really cannot play a 5 looks very
very strange was you know not sure maybe
I left 5 I could I could even consider
taking an f5 and maybe then I'll already
have a sacrifice going here yeah this
was possible of course but I thought
night III to d5 would be problematic now
I'll go there no maybe Bishop g5 yeah
but this looks really ugly okay it's
it's it's so so sadly a playable for
like it fairly solid but it's looking
ugly
yeah I'm not be three ab should be three
maybe not sure
you
yes usual I lost quite some time here
the porno with the bishop difficult
yeah I think with the poor should be
better idea also to support yeah okay
but it's not threatening to take you
ready still pinned here with the rogue
and what should you do this makes a
strange impression let's play that Queen
to see to attack this pawn on e4 and now
daiji 526 maybe maybe it's got something
like I'm should g5 then and possible
this is possible yeah bishop of sex is
somewhat inconvenient
yeah now I'm terribly slow and slow um
well all the time but this break of two
weeks didn't help much I think covering
g5
difficult position yeah maybe he's
threatening h6 but not one hundred
percent sure has a severe threat 96 also
h6 is hanging so it's it's not a real
threat let's try a three here my problem
as usual as a time
we're completely forgot that that I was
Queen age seven is actually protecting
the bishop here that's a shame really
this wasn't of course what I wanted to
have okay this is very inconvenient of
course need to get something going here
free up the rooks as fast as possible
yeah it's not it's not completely
hopeless or something at least doesn't
doesn't make the event impression that
it should be our rookie form maybe looks
like a problem okay didn't do that
yeah this is not exactly brilliant play
wit time of course yeah me too now which
is this just this one probably this is
just winning for black okay not sure
this is all together clear okay this was
really bad technical play by black still
clearly better frame of course okay now
it's not even better not sure what he's
doing check check
it's just playing on time I think check
check yeah and it was working yeah I've
no time he played this I don't know
what's good to same from completely
winning two to nothing okay yeah really
rusty plane I'm never really quick but
this was just just to slow the of course
this is no problem at all for white to
at least have equal player but I don't I
don't have the time left to to make
decent moves okay I think I need to need
a couple of games to two get the at
least some sort of time management and
playing rhythm going again okay let's
let's do another one